depuis le 13 février une exposition jeu
est visible depuis la terrasse de la
crêperie le reste au théâtre juste à
côté du théâtre et cinéma de
fontenay-le-fleury célia garçons goron
soir tête avec nos dons soir alors
expliquez nous un peu comment on peut
jouer et bien déjà le décor se compose
de neuf mannequin avec des costumes de
théâtre dans cette scène romantique d'un
repas pour la saint valentin
vingt-et-une erreur plus ou moins facile
de se sont glissés bien sûr pour que
toute la famille puisse jouer par
exemple un téléphone portable dans une
main d'un personnage ou une assiette
retourné sur une table dressée
ensuite vous trouverez sur le site
internet le formulaire réponse jeu pour
noter au tout les coquilles que vous
aurez trouvé le but de cette exposition
intérieur de continuer à proposer des
projets culturels
alors pour nous c'est une manière de
montrer le théâtre est pas fermée une
manière de montrer qu'on est vivant
parce que ce que les gens savent pas
c'est qu'on est quand même autorisé à
vous savez mettre en scène a travaillé à
répéter des spectacles et donc on était
triste de laisser en de laisser croire
aux gens que le théâtre était mort en
fait voyez qu on était touchant parce
qu'on avait déserté donc on a ensuite
dit voilà pas car cette initiative est
donc que peut-on gagner c'est bien bien
dix lots sont à gagner
ce seront 10 gagnants qui auront
retrouvé le plus grand nombre de bonnes
réponses en cas d'égalité un tirage au
sort sera effectué et ce sont des lots
très différent écouter on faire une
séance nous d'esthétique et la complète
sans toutefois plus de mâcon faire des
repas et la conférence est vraiment
sympa franche maison jouets jeux parce
que nous modestement faisait pas ça pour
l'argent puisque en plus c'est gratuit
tout ça donc on a fait ça pour
redynamiser un que montrer qu 4 août et
vivra que la ville soit liberty malgré
tout il expose se déroule jusqu'au 31
mars et petites infos injuste il le
théâtre de fontenay est aussi un cinéma
il propose donc des diffusions gratuites
en ligne chaque semaine de spectacles
comme la fleur au fusil par exemple et
ses diffusions sont suivies seulement le
dimanche après midi d'un échange avec
les acteurs du spectacle
merci célia agathe sango d'avoir été
avec nous on vous retrouve bien
évidemment
vendredi pour le 7-8 week end oui bien
sûr